[Music]
i've been trying to tell this story for
30 years
and the dominant experience i've had is
seeing the new evidence come in at first
month by month and week by week now
they're
studies every day practically and it
just keeps getting
clearer and stronger america's on the
verge of technological breakthroughs
that will enable us to live our lives
less dependent on oil
and these technologies will help us be
better stewards of the environment
and they will help us to confront the
serious challenge of global climate
change
[Applause]
now to a new report on global warming
from a prestigious panel of scientists
convened by the u.n
the findings are blunt climate change is
happening
it will lead to tremendous changes
around the world that could have a very
negative impact
on the well-being of people animals and
entire ecosystems
the evidence is sufficient that we
should move
towards the most effective possible
steps to reduce carbon loading of the
atmosphere i i think we have to accept
the view that
scientists have that there is global
warming and that
human operation human condition
contributes to that
i think the uh the risks of climate
change are real
and that you're seeing climate change i
think human activity is contributing to
it
why has it taken so long senator special
interest
it's a special interest it's the utility
companies and
the petroleum companies and the other
special interests they're the ones that
that have blocked progress in the in the
congress the united states and in the
administration
that's a little straight talk we don't
always see eye to eye
do we know no but we do agree our
country must take action to address
climate change i believe that climate
change is real it's not just a
greenhouse gas
issue it's a national security issue we
have an obligation to future generations
to take action and fix it
the senate is doing going to do
something today beginning a debate
on global warming a comprehensive
bill to deal with climate change that is
favorably reported out of a senate
committee
the yeas are 48
the nays are 36. three-fifths of the
senators julie chosen and sworn
not having voted in the affirmative the
motion is not
agreed to i believe that
man's activities certainly can be
contributing to
the issue of global warming climate
change here in alaska the only arctic
state
in our union of course we see the
effects of climate change more so than
any other area i think most members
think that the climate change is a
serious issue that needs to be addressed
the question is how do you address it
and and we've never gotten into the
the debate and the discussion about the
consequences of trying to deal with it
we need to ultimately make clean
renewable energy
the profitable kind of energy so i ask
this congress to send me legislation
that places a market-based cap on carbon
pollution
and drives the production of more
renewable energy in america
a sweeping climate change bill that's a
top item on president obama's agenda
passed maryland the house of
representatives last night only eight
republicans crossed the aisle to vote
with most democrats
for the bill 44 democrats joined most
republicans in voting against it
stolen emails from top researchers were
posted online
global warming skeptics saying those
emails suggest that
scientists may have worked together to
manipulate global warming data
defenders say those emails are being
used out of context president obama has
said that people are justified in being
disappointed by the outcome of the
copenhagen climate change conference
last week
in an interview on u.s television mr
obama acknowledged that nothing had been
done to achieve a significant cut in
greenhouse gases
but he said that the non-binding
agreement reached in denmark was better
than nothing
top u.s scientists urged drastic action
today to slow global warming
for the first time the national academy
of sciences called for a specific change
in climate policy it recommended a
carbon tax on fossil fuels
or a cap and trade system for greenhouse
gas emissions
senate democrats pushed the climate bill
off the table and into a very uncertain
future ahead of november's midterm
elections
and i'll take dad aim at the cap and
trade bill the republican takeover of
the house
is likely to change the political
climate on the issue of global warming
and it is safe to say that the
president's cap and trade
legislation that whole idea is virtually
dead most republicans say they will
scrap the select committee on global
warming speaker designate john boehner
called the panel quote
a forum to promote democrats job-killing
national
energy tax also known as cap and trade
but when you have
over 90 percent of the world scientists
who have studied this stating that
climate change is occurring
and that humans play a contributing role
it's time to defer to the experts
listen when you when you make comments
that fly in the face of what
98 out of 100 climate scientists have
said
when you call into question the science
of evolution all i am saying
is that in order for the republican
party to win
we can't run from science the science is
is not settled on this
and i tell somebody i said just because
you have a group of scientists that have
stood up and said here
is the fact galileo got uh out voted for
a spell
my view is that we don't know what's
causing
climate change on this planet and the
idea of spending trillions and trillions
of dollars to try and reduce co2
emissions is not the right course for us
the white house today finalized new gas
mileage standards that would eventually
double the fuel efficiency of new cars
and trucks
to an average 54 and a half miles per
gallon
by 2025. obama can't get through
climate change legislation so the epa is
going to use its authority to do what it
can
in that regard president obama promised
to begin to slow the rise of the oceans
[Applause]
and to heal the planet
[Music]
my promise is to help you and your
family
[Music]
74 of us senate republicans
publicly question the science of global
warming but this is a challenge that
does not pause for partisan gridlock it
demands our attention
now the age of the dinosaurs was
dramatically
warmer than this is right now and it
didn't cook the planet
and in fact life was fine are you
convinced that climate change is
man-made
well i i look i i don't know
that that is a resolved issue in science
today
you do not think that human activity the
production of co2
has caused warming tomorrow i do not
believe that human activity
is causing these dramatic changes to our
climate
the way these scientists are portraying
it do you believe in man-made climate
change
democrats 83 say yes republicans 36
say yes it is now as more divisive than
abortion
it has in recent years become ideology
it's become partisan
the obama administration has just rolled
out a new rule to cut carbon dioxide
emissions from power plants the proposal
from the environmental protection agency
cuts co2 emissions by 30 percent by
2030. some democrats in coal mining
states
want him to hold off until after the
midterm elections
in november the world's top climate
panel has issued its direst appeal to
date on the need to stop global warming
in a new report the united nations
intergovernmental panel on climate
change says continued emissions of
greenhouse gases
will cause further warming and
long-lasting changes in
all components of the climate system
increasing the likelihood of severe
pervasive and irreversible impacts
scientists report that 2014 was the
hottest year in recorded history for the
planet
and that dates back to 1880. satellite
data demonstrate for the last 17 years
there's been zero warming none
whatsoever we are seeing
these horrible uh the reports are now in
palmyra they're
executing people and leaving their
bodies uh
in the streets meanwhile the president
of the united states is saying that the
biggest
enemy we have is climate change we've
had one record-setting year after
another as far as
as as far as the the heat on on this
planet so
i don't buy that joe what do you mean
you don't buy it i just don't buy that
i don't buy the fact that it's a crisis
i don't buy the fact that it's a crisis
i just don't
i think that there'll be little change
here it'll go up it'll get a little
cooler or get a little warmer like it
always has for
millions of years it'll get cooler it'll
get warmer it's called weather
i think it's a big scam for a lot of
people to make a lot of money
in my first inaugural address i
committed
this country to the tireless task of
combating climate change
and protecting this planet for future
generations
two weeks ago in paris i said before the
world
that we needed a strong global agreement
to accomplish this goal an enduring
agreement that reduces
global carbon pollution and sets the
world on a course to a low-carbon future
a few hours ago we succeeded the
question now
is this agreement just paper or will it
lead to crucial steps needed to make it
something
truly historic feeling the heat so is
planet earth federal scientists
announced today
that 2015 was the warmest year on record
with land and ocean temperatures
nearly two degrees above average a major
setback tonight
for president obama's climate change
initiative the u.s supreme court stepped
in to put the centerpiece of president
obama's climate change agenda on hold
pending the outcome of judicial appeals
in the lower courts
trump's statement comes just a couple
days after he released his first energy
plan he says he would quote cancel
the paris climate deal and promote more
fossil fuels in the united states donald
thinks that climate change is
a hoax perpetrated by the chinese i
think it's real please we cannot
keep sending climate deniers and defeat
us
to congress or state houses and
certainly not to the white house
nasa and noaa scientists today declared
2016 the hottest year on record
out of the 17 hottest years on record 16
have occurred since 2000.
the united states will withdraw
from the paris
climate accord
[Music]
thank you german chancellor angela
merkel called it extremely regrettable
canadian prime minister justin trudeau
called it disheartening
and the vatican went further saying mr
trump's decision
was a disaster for everyone meanwhile
president trump is ending obama's
signature
environmental policy that limits carbon
emissions from power plants that burn
coal
speaking to an audience in kentucky
yesterday epa administrator scott pruitt
said that the regulation
violated federal law and declared that
the war on coal
is over 2017 was the third warmest year
on record
the six hottest years have all been
since 2010.
the window of opportunity to prevent
global climate chaos
is not yet closed but according to a
landmark report it will require
action on an unprecedented scale the
message is
over to governments at this stage we've
told you the scientific facts the
evidence the costs
it is up to the governments now to
decide what to do with it
you